halt dich ist wieder eure x banner und
euer thomas danke du passt auf die
zeitungen auf und ich mache hier weit
okay
downey junior noch nicht so wirklich
okay wobei ich der ein oder andere von
euch hat es vielleicht schon mitbekommen
ich war in so vielen zeitungen drin da
ziehen meine ich natürlich zum beispiel
in der lobby downey junior zeitschrift
bunte sich jetzt die neue hobby downey
junior zeitung schrift jetzt die neue
jetzige vom alberne dieses ist perry die
dort film music lifestyle welches jemand
gesehen und sogar im festival magazin
auch wieder das gleiche bild
das ist mein schmal und daneben red bull
red bull hat ist auch handyverträge
nicht immer so komisch aus wenn die
katzen
ich bin nicht verrückt ich bin ja so und
nur so eine katze hervor teilte nach
unten wenn ich das machen will
hallo
ich bin nicht verrückt und ich war auch
in der pace so ganz nebenbei in der neon
natürlich auch in der mädchen hier
hinten da hab ich auch tatsächlich von
euch ein paar nach hingekriegt so saß im
bus dann habe ich jemanden gesehen der
die dringend gepunktet
in der tv spielfilm jetzt kommen wir
aber zu dem interessanten tag eine story
noch shape ich habe dann diese ganzen
zeitschriftenverlag bekommen dann lagen
die hier bei mir irgendwie natürlich
auch angefangen da reinzuschauen gerade
zeitschrift man dann habe ich hier eine
scheibe workout gefunden für einen
flachen bauch in zwei wochen mit zehn
minuten training pro tag ich dachte mir
kann ich jetzt gebrauchen also los
machen wir mal dieses zehn minuten
training das war vor drei tagen jetzt
ist gerade mein muskelkater wieder ich
hatte drei tage den allerschlimmsten
muskelkater den ich nee ich hab genießt
und es hat sich angefühlt wie ich habe
genießt und es hat sich angefühlt als ob
jemand mit messer in meinem bauch
stechen wird hommels du bist hier über
thomas du bist hier überall gibt
ich weiß nicht was ich in der chef zu
suchen habe aber jetzt die seite shape
und jetzt fragt ihr euch warum habe ich
kein heil sein spaß hast du gerade
ehrlich ein video in dem du nur darüber
spricht dass du in sämtlichen
zeitschriften drin war es definitiv nein
denn jetzt kommen wir zum eigentlichen
thema was ich ansprechen wollte dass ich
auch in der cosmopolitan drin war
los gehts gar nicht zuerst dachte ich
keine werbeanzeige in der cosmopolitan
eigentlich passe ich da jetzt nicht so
wirklich rein aber hey schaut mich an
gleich ist aber potenzial ich habe mir
natürlich dann auch die cosmopolitan
genauer angeschaut weil das letzte mal
gesehen habe ist schon eine lange zeit
her so ersten zwei seiten werk nach
werbung für uhren dann kommt das
impressum werbung werbung und dann kommt
er in heil werbung bewerbung wäre wohl
der werbe und werbung werbung der
werbung wer wo ein ganzes werbung für
wohnbau zwei seiten artikel schaffen wir
es auf der doppelseite werbung fünf
seiten h&m werbung aus mir raus geflogen
um werbung ja schön ich leute ich
mittendrin in dieser scheiße nur um es
klarzustellen ich bin nicht von gestern
ich weiß dass zeitschriften sich auch
durch werbung finanzieren müsste es gibt
also einen klitzekleinen punkt der mich
besonders näher und 23 euro drei euro
bezahlst du um diese zeitschrift zukauft
du siehst im laden dieses magazin und
denkst dir das auch nicht was drin das
ist ja dick und groß und schwer
ja ich würde jetzt noch mal ganz
ungefähr behaupten dass 50% in diesem
magazin werbungen und das ist dann doch
ein bisschen verarsche weil du halt das
gefühl hast du kaufst was du kaufst viel
für drei euro und am ende bezahlte geld
dafür dass du dir werbung an gucken kann
und ein bisschen artikeln
es ist doch scheiße sieht jetzt bei mir
aus wie in der zahnarztpraxis oder tisch
genommen
im wartezimmer warte so welche
zeitschrift lesen sich heute wie
cosmopolitan bestimmt nicht die ist ja
gar nicht mal so schlecht würde ich
sagen ausser sie meine
zwillingsschwester genommen haben statt
mich fürs cover glücklich dass ich auf
dem cover rein darf ich glaub nicht das
ist eine disco sagen muss aber sagen ob
alle ich liebe ich trotzdem discover
jetzt bin ich genauso verrückt wie katja
glaser wird katja schnabeltasse hellmann
süßen und jetzt kommt mein eigentliches
problem es gibt werbung im magazin blink
blink anzeigen den times square als voll
damit und dann irgendwann kommen die
youtube videos produzieren wie ich jetzt
gerade das so machen und du schaust
gerade einmal ob es dir immer gefällt
oder nicht ob du mich magst oder
nächsten chance ist die an das ist etwa
fakt ist dass hier auf dem tuch und ja
wir youtuber machen das alle super gerne
das ist macht uns super viel spaß wir
haben so ein glück dass wir das auch
machen können dass wir die zeit finden
dass wir vielleicht dann sogar so viel
geld damit verdienen könnt dass es das
für miete und so reich und ich finde das
so unfair dass es halt ständig so
angeprangert wird dass die youtuber geld
verdienen natürlich jeder muss geld
verdienen und da sollte man sich echt
nicht beständen wir haben ein werbeclip
vor dem video
ich will nur mit dem video sagen es gibt
verbrecher die dir das hier auf
schwarzem
und keiner beschwert sich ist okay wenn
ihr euch darüber aufregt dass einer geld
verdienen dann schaut aber nicht seinen
videos an die es ja auch nicht an ein
bäcker bei dem du keine brötchen kaufen
willst und dann kaufst du ein brötchen
aber bezahlt sich dafür steht ihr das
naja bis bald ach ja und wer den adblock
aber youtube nicht ausmachen ist richtig
kacke